it is a historic moment they've raised
interest rates more in one go than they
have done for more than three decades
there is a brief moment in 1992 where
they raised them by a little bit more
than this only lasted 24 hours so really
this is the single biggest increase that
we've had since 1989. it is a big moment
obviously they've been raising rates
quite quickly in recent months as well
now up to three percent that will have
an instant bearing if you have a
floating rate mortgage it'll have an
instant bearing on your mortgage and of
course it will also have a bearing on
many other kind of borrowing costs
across the economy but yes as you say
Anna there are all sorts of other things
going on as well because the bank
doesn't just provide their decision on
interest rates they also give us a sense
of how the economy is doing right now
I'm afraid the story there isn't
especially good they say that we are
already in recession right now the
recession has already begun in the third
quarter of the year and it could well
and I'm just saying this to couch it
slightly it could well last a long time
maybe as long as four quarters of
success of successive contraction and
when we're talking about recession what
does it mean it means the economy gross
domestic products basically shrinking
and the technical definition of
recession is just when it's shrinking
for two quarters in a row but in Broad
terms it means we are not in a good
place the total amount the sum total of
income we're generating across the
economy is shrinking they say it could
be a very long very protracted recession
indeed but there's a massive Proviso
over that which is that they're
concerned that right now markets and
when we're talking about markets we're
all pretty familiar with this now from
the last few weeks money markets uh out
there guilt markets uh the markets where
people are making decisions about
whether they're buying into the UK what
they're doing with UK government debt
they say they are expecting higher
interest rates than really look likely
they've given a really firm signal
firmer than I can remember in a long
time to suggest that well markets at the
moment think the rates could be heading
up towards about five percent the bank
signals that's not necessarily likely so
in a paradoxical way although they're
raising rates by 0.75 that's a big
amount they're saying the eventual peak
in interest rates might not be be as
high as a lot of people had expected
which could of course have a bearing on
what we're seeing in markets at the
moment it could mean that floating that
fixed rate mortgages which of course are
based on those expectations could
actually start to go down a little bit
and in response to this but really we
have to wait and see we have to see how
the how markets react and I'll have a
look at I mean I literally haven't
looked at that since I came up in the
vaults to get that analysis but we'll
also see what the governor has to say so
we'll be hearing from the governor
Andrew Bailey in a press conference and
we'll be talking to him on Sky News a
little bit later on as well but yes a
big day for the UK economy interest
rates Rising faster than we've seen in
any previous decision from the bank of
England in three decades getting up to
three percent and it essentially
diagnoses that we are already in a
recession that could really be quite
protracted
and did they say anything about
where inflation would Peak
so their expectation of inflation is
kind of more or less going to Peak kind
of roundabout now so so you've got that
moment in October when that uh we get
that increase in Energy prices the
energy price guarantee of course meaning
it's going to be 25 pound 500 pounds on
average on our households that's about
11 inflation they're expecting around
now but then it stays pretty high and a
lot depends to be honest with you and
they don't really know about this either
it depends on what the government does
in April when that six months comes to
an end and when it basically decides
what it's going to do with Energy prices
in future we don't know about that yet
and the other big thing actually that
the bank doesn't know about and it's
another reason to be a little bit
cautious I mean there is no getting away
from these numbers they do not look good
the economy in recession right now
potentially it could be quite a
protracted recession although it's worth
saying you know when we're talking about
the length of the recession that's the
length of time the depth of the
recession so how far it goes down how
much of a dentist making in all of our
incomes across the economy that's not as
bad according to their forecasts even in
those kind of quite gloomy forecasts
that's not as bad as we saw in 2008 uh
it's not as bad as we saw in the 1980s
it's kind of comparable with what we saw
in the 1990s but you've got these other
factors You've Got High inflation uh
which of course you've mentioned You've
Got High Energy prices which are a part
of that in fact a big part of that and
then you've got higher mortgage costs
and that's obviously what we've just had
formalized in the Bank of England today
bringing up those mortgage costs for
households across the country and you're
facing that kind of three different
factors coming at you from all different
sides which means that the amount of
kind of spare income that people have
over the course of the next few years
won't be as much and that's what's
pushing the UK into this recession right
now of course we will hear as well from
the chancellor uh Jeremy Hunt about what
their plans are I mean you know they
have their Autumn statement coming up
they're unlike to give any kind of uh
hints about what they're going to do but
it's worth saying what this has done is
laid out a pretty bleak outlook for the
UK economy ahead of that decision and of
course if they are going to be cutting
spending raising taxes on top of all of
this that might well mean that the dip
video economy is even worse in the
coming years so it's pretty tough times
a couple of other things I should
mention unemployment the bank talking
about unemployment getting up to a peak
of around six and a half percent maybe
even higher than that that would be the
highest that we've seen since the
financial crisis of course it was kind
of up at eight percent or so during the
financial crisis and the other issue is
mortgages they think that on average if
you've got a mortgage then your costs
obviously it all depends on when you're
refixing but your costs could go up on
average by about three thousand pound
that's an average figure but three
thousand pounds now bear in mind that
that is actually bigger than any kind of
compensation that households are getting
those who have mortgages from the energy
price guarantee you see the issue you've
got Energy prices really high at the
same time those mortgage costs coming up
as well and the bank's saying in order
to get inflation down it's having to
raise interest rates right now which is
making life tougher for everyone so
unfortunately there's you know bits of
news that aren't especially palatable
there